uh so this is in the daily mail
dog owners face 75 78 higher risk of
catching covet
wow this is an ad riff yeah
dog owners face 78 higher risk of
catching cover 19 and home grocery
deliveries double the risk study fines
um that's the headline okay
there are a number of headlines that uh
that looked a bit like this
uh also among headlines you know
screamed from the headlines masks don't
do any good but
uh but cleaning your groceries when you
get home does that sort of thing
so uh this sounds both alarming
and also really inconsistent
with a lot of what we have come to
understand
yeah just a reminder for those who have
come
to our our live streams our podcast
since
the end of may when we started we
started on march 24th i think was our
first one
specifically to talk about covet and our
first 16 or so episodes were almost
entirely about kovid
and we really walked through some of the
some of the
evidence that was coming out for what
was true about it and
some of the politicizing of it and all
of this and
you know this result if true this set of
results if true
really goes counter to so much of what
we think we understand
yeah and so for those who've been around
from the beginning of our live streams
you watched our model develop and indeed
at the very beginning we were quite
concerned about what are called fomites
which are
viral particles that are transmitted um
on surfaces which is a very common way
for viruses to be transmitted but it
became clear over time that that was
less prevalent
in in the case of covid and so this
study
uh a presumably people walking their dog
are doing it outside
that should be fairly safe chasing their
dog
chasing their dog around their kitchen
island yeah all right i mean
but so anyway there's something weird
about you know the alarm over
uh walking the dog there's something
weird about um the idea
that uh having stuff delivered to your
house
is dangerous of groceries groceries
being delivered to your house
uh appears to have contained within it a
greater risk of contracting covert than
going out grocery shopping for yourself
right right that's one of the results as
well
seems to make little sense because
having them delivered to your home
eliminates whatever
confined spaces you might face uh in the
grocery store
or in vehicles or whatever
so anyway there's a lot here that raises
alarm bells either
the um either the study is in some way
flawed
or the model that we have been building
up
is deeply flawed and so anyway yes it uh
it does raise exactly that question yeah
uh i'm sorry my computer is
not behaving yeah thank you
there we go thank you um
let us if you would show this for just a
moment zach this is the actual paper
um it has a publication date for those
who read
publication dates of 2021 just meaning
that here is the
uh is the early publication online but
it is
it has been peer reviewed it is due to
actually be published in this form
early in 2021 with the headline the
spread of sarsko v2 in spain
hygiene habits sociodemographic profile
mobility patterns and co-morbidities
okay let me walk us through
just a little bit about what they tried
to do before we talk about some of the
results
and i guess you know spoiler alert
it does not seem that we should be
overly concerned about the results
screaming from the headlines as a result
of this research because
i at least have very little faith that
these results are going to end up being
meaningful having now
spent some time with the paper itself so
for a few reasons
the methods were a survey an online
survey of
people's activities that is self-reports
self-reports are often
somewhat unreliable people remember
different things that are than are
actually true
but fair enough it's a fairly common
social science
mode however basically encouraging
people whoever feels i get to go online
is um and and fill out a survey is
not the most rigorous way of getting
self-reports from people of having
people take a survey
and the survey was taken or was um
was asking about the period of most
intense
lockdown in spain so everyone remembers
um this
early early mid spring when spain
and parts of italy were in such high
lockdown that people weren't were
really discouraged even from leaving
their homes right
so this is all of the results
if they are trustworthy based on these
self-reports
are about a period during which
all of the most intense methods of
transmission
as far as we understand the virus had
already been eradicated right so there
was
there was no there was very little
working in offices although there was
some there was discouraging of
um of social events there was you know i
think basically complete cut
shutdown just as in most of the us of
most of the retail sector except for
essential businesses
and so that that alone need
forces us to recalibrate our estimate of
what something like a 78
increase in a risk of contracting a
virus
when walking your dog say would mean
because that 78
increase is compared to a rate that has
already been drastically reduced
by the fact of the lockdowns that the
government has imposed
that's true that's just something to be
aware of when thinking about how to
calibrate
internally what these numbers might mean
but here's the point in the paper where
i really started to question whether or
not we should be believing anything in
this
it's in the statistical analysis so
quote
considering that the capacity of
diagnostic tests in spain was not
sufficient
two affirmative categories were
introduced one of them was affirmative
by diagnosis
and the other by patient self-report
what that means in english as opposed to
sciences
is in order to assess so they you know
they asked people did you walk your dog
did you take the metro did you
you know did you work from home all of
these things and then separate they also
asked everyone did you or did you not
have coven
and those people who ended up at the yes
i had covered column ended up there by
one of two ways
either they had an actual diagnosis from
a test or they said
yes i suspect i had coven yes i suspect
i had covid
is indistinguishable within the results
of this study from
yes i had a test and and it came back
positive for covid
and not only that not only are those two
categories which are
wickedly different um combined and
impossible to untangle in these results
but fully half fully half of the
affirmative cases
are coded as self-reports all right so
a number of things one wonderful
teachable moments in here
yeah so many one thing to say is that
were it the case that self-reports and
self-diagnosis
were random in their
nature then all that you would need to
do to correct for the problems of them
being
important to the methodology of the
study is have a larger data set
the problem and increasingly this is
something i think a
huge fraction even of the educated
sophisticated part of the population is
not
grocking is that everything changes when
you have a systematic error
rather than a random error a random
error
sounds worse in some ways because um
you can't fix it right you can't ever
get rid of them it sounds like it's very
uh destructive
of data but really the point is it just
it's like a noisy restaurant where
somebody's talking to you it's
it's random stuff and you can find the
signal
through it and increase your sample as
you just said increase your sample size
in order to
decrease the effective random error
that's how you do it right
the problem is systematic error
especially systematic error that you're
in no position to estimate
creates a whole different problem and it
does not go away with a bigger sample
size in fact it can get worse
um you can reinforce the sense that
something is there that isn't
and so the question is how likely is it
in a world
where people are self-diagnosed that
their tendency to self-diagnose
incorrectly is correlated to some
other thing in their personality right
their tendency to report that they've
walked their dog when they haven't right
maybe
you know who knows what it will be
correlated to but the chances
that it is a random factor are low and
we are in a very poor position to say
what else it will be correlated with
and therefore one has to worry that
there might be false signal in here
rather than just a bunch of noise
yeah and the numbers aren't aren't that
big
so even if some of the error is random
uh we
we should expect that it will actually
be conveyed here as well
yeah um okay so
with regard to the results like all of
those those
oh hold on so we've got um it's a survey
not actual known data on what people
were really doing we've got self reports
where people we know
will lie about things that make them
look to the outside or
feel better inside about themselves it
is about a moment in time when the most
extreme lockdown was happening
and therefore when people were in fact
the most worried
and the most confused the most alarmed
and probably the most likely to
mistakenly self-diagnose right and the
statistical analysis itself the way
that positive um that positive
covid diagnosis is assessed is is deeply
suspect
all of that said we can talk about the
results knowing that maybe the results
don't mean anything like what they
what they say they made and i and i
intend to but you wanted to say
something yeah i wanted to say something
which is just
um as a scientifically sophisticated but
not
expert in this particular area person
i would say one thing that is a red flag
for me
is that it's hard to imagine a mechanism
whereby walking one's dog increases
transmission
assuming that i've got a couple i've got
a couple possible so i i've thought this
through two and i've come up with some
stuff that might work
um and in fact would match some errors
i've seen elsewhere so we'll come back
let's see if we've got the same stuff
let's just let's just kind of spell this
out before we go into the details
in a little while which is that okay if
if you have a result that you trust
the next thing you do is um in this case
would be well
well why then what you know what is the
mechanism you know that's surprising
again we don't think this is a
legitimate result i i don't anyway
but if it's true then the next question
should be why
does walking the dog cause an increase
in
in covert risk and from there you would
want to posit all the possible
hypotheses and then test
them so it's an addition it's not it's
not going back and replicating the
original data that you tried to take but
it's now testing
a new observation that is the result of
a previous scientific test
to figure out to get more granularity on
the y on the mechanism of why the result
is what you think it is
again that all hinges on the idea that
the initial result is true which
i don't see any reason to think that it
necessarily is right and i'm not saying
that there's
any way that you can look at a result
like that and say it's too surprising to
be true
we can come up with various you know
shocking ways that it could be true and
sometimes shocking things do turn out to
be true but
my point would just be okay i've
walked dogs okay i have some sense of
what that typically looks like and i
don't have any reason to think that my
experience walking a dog
is particularly unusual a people
tend to do it during the day i'm not
saying 100
but maybe it's 80 right so uv light they
tend to do it outside
right they tend when they interact with
other people
one is often at a distance because
you've got dogs and a leash circling
each other whatever so it's not like
you're right up in each other's faces
when you talk to somebody that you meet
while walking the dog all of these
things should tend to keep rates of
transmission very low
rather than make them high um and you
know
particularly conspicuous is just the
fact that outdoors seems to at least so
far during the pandemic have been
terrifically protective
even at night even when there's no uv so
you would need some other kind of
mechanism now i'm curious what did what
did you come up with
um in terms of possibilities if this
result was right
a couple of things one excuse me is um
actually goes a little bit counter to
what you just one of the things you just
said which is that um
especially during a time of social
lockdown early on when people still hope
that it was maybe you know a month or
two
um but we're really going out of their
minds um as as people are again of
course
um with suddenly being socially isolated
uh walking your dog and seeing a
neighbor or seeing someone
you know even whom you don't know but
whom your dog you know someone else is
walking their dog and your dog wants to
meet them
this is a perfect excuse even for the
for the most
coveted concerned you know even for the
most hawkish among us
uh uh with regard to kovid to
let the dogs sniff each other and
perhaps get a little bit closer than you
should and to have a little conversation
and if in addition uh neither of the
people walking their dogs are wearing
their masks because it's outside why
would you
and you do not in in a moment when
you're actually talking with
that person um put on a mask then there
may well be a possibility of
transmission there
that said there was a result from you
know many i think tens of thousands of
people
out of china early on that i talked
about in one of our first episodes
that showed that across tens of
thousands of cases where they could
track transmission literally
one of them was trackable to an outside
interaction now it was an outside
interaction
between neighbors talking right right so
so there's there's that possibility
which is
um which i think is not very likely but
i you know i have i did at one point not
walking a dog but have a drink outside
with a friend actually nancy rommelman
um at some point you know in the late
summer
and we were sitting across from each
other at a table outside and the sun was
coming in
sufficiently that i could see as if
either of us talked and
like spittle would come out of our mouth
like oh
maybe we should be sitting on the same
side of the table physically closer
but whatever is coming out of us is
going to go not into each other's drinks
or whatever
our noses but actually away from one
another so i do think that um you know
close close facing each other outside
and talking
is going to be a better route for
transmission than sort of being side by
side that's one thing
and then there's of course the
possibility that there's dog to dog
transmission and dog-to-person
transmission
and there is not um evidence of
this yet but there is um some suggestive
evidence that it might be possible
and hold on specifically not just people
walking their dogs and meeting other
people walking their dogs
um but this research did not ask about
whether or not if you walk your dog you
also took your dog to a dog park
and so dog park is going to be and i
can't think dog park now without
thinking about that rape and dog parks
paper that the grief and studies people
put together but
um you're a gonna be in a much more
social situation both with people and
with dogs and if there is transmission
between dogs and dogs to people then
that would be
a pretty good place for it to happen so
okay
so this this gets tangled here because
the fact
were transmission from dogs to people
um not just possible let's grant that
even if it has never happened it might
still be possible
sure but were it a route
that was likely then we would
certainly have had lots of opportunity
to discover it
because there has been lots of interest
in dogs and cats and they're contracting
covid and in epidemiological circles
what transmits to what is a very
important factor so the point is it's an
obvious question now that doesn't mean
people have looked at it but i will be
shocked if nobody has looked into the
question of
uh dog to person transmission and so if
this paper is detecting
dog to people transmission um well again
this paper is completely agnostic on
that
right that's my point if it's detecting
it without specifying it as a mechanism
that's a remarkable
thing and again
the the thing that is most glaring here
is how robust
the this doesn't seem to transmit
outdoors result
is and the fact that it would have to
transmit outdoors here either between
people walking their dogs or dogs to
people
something has to be happening and that
is so contrary to
the model that has developed and
robustly so because of course the
question
of protests and whether they were going
to create a massive
wave um and the fact is they don't seem
to have which you and i
said i i will be careful about saying we
predicted it but we did say
there's a strong possibility they won't
because these things tend to be outdoors
and for whatever reason
probably multiple reasons outdoors does
not appear to be consistent with
uh spreader events yeah so did you have
what did you generate was it was it like
what i did or what did you generate with
regard to possible mechanisms
if this result is true yeah and walking
your dog actually
is associated with an increased risk of
contracting covet as opposed to not
having a doug or not walking your dog at
all which is which was
those were the lumped categories um what
other mechanisms that we haven't yet
talked about to degenerate
i was wondering so in a prior case which
i was unable to
find but there was a an alarming
report of a paper that suggested
spreader events at protests or
uh maybe it was beach parties or
something like that
and i was i thought oh my god has this
thing evolved to be transmissible
outdoors which is one of the things you
and i have worried about that it doesn't
transmit outdoors but it could learn
that trick if we're not
careful and in any case i went to the um
paper and it was like oh there was no
evidence it was being transmitted
outdoors there was some other
phenomenon that was lumped in here that
involved
indoor contact between people right
so in this case i was wondering if under
lockdown conditions walking one's dog
resulted in something like
you know going into a coffee shop right
now maybe
coffee shops weren't open at that time
but i was imagining that there might be
something
that people who were outside because
they were walking their dog were doing
that wasn't outside that could be
some route well i think uh if i can pull
it up here i think oh actually i have it
on
paper i think that's unlikely to be true
just because um
where what kinds of uh retail outlets
people went into is in here
and they don't ask coffee shop but they
ask
um have you been to a supermarket green
grocery butchery bakery
pharmacy tobacco shop bank
medical care center uh and for none of
those
um was was there a significant uh
increase in likelihood of contracting
according to this data set which is
which i don't trust suspect right right
so
all i'm saying i don't think that's
likely at all but if the result
was robust which you and i both suspect
it isn't but
if it was robust that's one of the
places i would look is is there some
behavior
that is captured by you know within
walking the dog that isn't
recorded in the data that is actually
responsible for the transmission but
it's something that's very likely in
some sorry in some ways that's the same
that's the same category as my
well if you're the kind of person who
walks your dog you may be also the kind
of person who goes to dog parks
right so it's like you know what what
else is in this category
um that you'd man you didn't manage to
collect with this survey
and um you know i'd like to see the dog
walking
versus um dog walking and dog park going
and um you might like to see the dog
walking
only versus dog walking and you know
going into other businesses while in the
dog walk something like that
um i guess one other there are a few
more results i want to talk about here
but
i will also say
where is it in the conclusions of the
paper the very end of the paper
i quote the results of this study
demonstrate that living with dogs
working on site purchasing essential
commodities by using home delivery
service
and especially living with a covet 19
patient have been the main roots of
transmission of saris cov2 during the
most restrictive period of confinement
in spain
now i hope that's just like a typo
but that is exactly the opposite of the
result that they actually found in this
paper and i went back and looked at
their results and now we don't have
access to the the actual the raw data
but
the results show that pet ownership is
not correlated with
you know again if we could trust these
data but you know
every single thing we say about this
paper is if we can trust the day and we
don't that we can
but using the data that they are talking
about here they find
that pet ownership is not correlated
with increased risk of covid
19 um whereas walking your dog is and
then the conclusions they say the
opposite they say something which they
absolutely 100 found not to be true
which you know that's that's a kind of
sloppiness that is
really not okay well i i agree that the
implication of that sentence is exactly
what you say and it
uh is counter to even um the patterns
and the data they
seem to think they have found there's a
way in which
um you could defend the sentence in
other words no no you
because because they specifically talk
about pet living with pets early in the
paper
right but like this it's not even like
we didn't look at that and so we're kind
of being sloppy in our talking
this is this is a thing that they
specifically looked at and they found no
evidence of it and they say they found
evidence of it
no no i get it it's completely
misleading but the fact is dog ownership
leads to dog walking and so if dog
walking
is where the transmission is happening
then dog ownership is the gateway no
totally not giving them a pass here
because they said they i'm not giving
them a pass no
they have people who say i have dogs but
i didn't walk them during the pandemic
because i was concerned right
people who have dogs who didn't walk
them show
no increased risk according to this data
set which i don't trust
but so no no like this is actually one
of the few places where they do have
granularity in terms of their categories
and then they lose that granularity and
say something that they did not find
even
in their conclusions well so here's the
problem is i mean i'm
defending a losing position because
basically no reasonable person could
interpret what they said that way but if
we go back and say what kind of error
was this i believe there's a logical
basis on which that sentence
and maybe you know i don't know if
there's a language issue here or not but
that's
that's also a question it's possible
that they arrived at something that
you know has a connotation that's
absolutely not justified but that if you
just look at the
um words that one it is not a false
statement
my hope is it's a it's a translation
issue but given that they
have they were careful in the rest of
the paper on this exact issue
i don't i i can't even begin to explain
that
so um two other results
again from an analysis of a data set
the analysis of which i don't you know
the data set i don't trust and the
analysis i don't trust
but one result uh is that
public transport uh taking public
transport did have a big effect
on on transmission risk in all the
categories they looked at
including buses trains and metros but
not taxis
interestingly so that that again is
consistent with the model that we have
that has been emerging that we've been
talking
about from the beginning which is that
small enclosed spaces with lots of
people
with relatively slow clearing of the air
and lots of people breathing into it
is going to be your high risk
environment whereas a taxi
with one person with one person uh
in it at a time plus you is going to be
lower risk
well actually i'm suspicious about this
now it's possible
you could have something like there was
wisdom circulating about
air circulation and people were opening
their windows
or that you know amongst uh taxi drivers
there was uh you know informal
discussion of
uh open the windows after somebody's
been in your vehicle before the next
person gets in or whatever
there could be something that would be
protected but my sense is
even given the contact with a much
smaller number of people
it happens in a cab that a cab would be
a very
dangerous a a place where there's a high
risk of transmission and b a place where
interventions could be massively
effective
right clearing the air by opening
windows or driving around with your
windows open as we have done
that is liable to be highly effective
and so
i i want to know what that why the taxis
show up as anomalous there yeah
uh and one more thing uh that the result
that um
cleaning your groceries when you got
home was effective at reducing the risk
of getting the virus but wearing masks
was not
struck me as maybe the most surprising
of all well
that is of course not what they found
again data or suspect analysis
is suspect but if the data are legit and
the analysis
is conveying conveying accurately what
is true
what they actually found is not that
mask wearing doesn't
protect against government 19 but that
mask wearing outside
doesn't protect against coveted 19 they
specifically ask people
when you go outside do you wear masks
and those people who did
did not suffer did not experience a
greater relief from getting covet 19 and
those people who did not
guess why because it's really hard to
get this thing while outside now that
does run
counter to this dog walking conclusion
but
it's not that masks don't protect
against covet 19 that's not what they
asked right
that is not what the study asked at all
so it's like
if we were to let me try to figure out
the exact analogy it would be like
deciding that knowing how to swim is not
protective against
drowning by surveying people who were on
land
right yeah yeah people who can't swim
are no more likely to drown strange as
that sounds
amazing i guess we just all know how to
swim yeah
or something yeah that's good right um
so
yeah and that that last thing that's not
the author's fault right the
the fact that the media take this and
run with it and make scare headlines to
sell you products that you don't need
is not the fault of the authors of this
study i do think there's plenty to
critique as we've already done
about it in the study um but the sort of
screaming from the headlines masks are
less effective than
cleaning your groceries when you get
home against covet 19 no
i'm not not in any way compelled and not
only that that's not even what the study
says
yep all right are you there because i
have a uh a question for you
are you there with respect to the study
or you have further you want to go
yeah i guess um maybe just one more
thing is that we um
we talk we've talked a lot about how
this virus might be evolving
and it i i've seen just a few you know i
mostly don't go and look at
you know comments and and and stuff uh
responding to
what it is that we've said but i've
begun to see a few things
that suggest that people are
misunderstanding that claim to mean that
our understanding of the virus is
evolving
that is also true for sure i think
everyone on the planet understands that
that is true at this point and that
early claims that were wrong were
sometimes wrong because they were
political
and the people making them knew they
were wrong like the surgeon general
saying don't wear masks they're not
helpful that sort of thing when they had
every reason to think that they were
but certainly some of what we have
thought to be true
we now don't think to be true and that's
not because there's deceit
going on but simply because we have a
better model now of what's true
so our understanding is evolving is one
true thing but it is also true
that the virus itself has every reason
to be evolving evolving
as it comes to infect more and more host
people
maybe other species as well across all
range of habitats and different seasons
with different amounts of indoor versus
outdoor social versus not social
engagement and so um
[Music]
we should we should be thinking about
even what we really really understand to
be true
about this virus back in march and
also be asking whether or not those
things
still hold now two-thirds of a year
later yeah
that's a really important point um
one caution is
what we know should go up over time
but that there is an analog to
the hazard that we described in i think
our last live stream
uh where as something becomes rare it
becomes
uh people become increasingly sentence
sensitive and start seeing it where it
isn't
to the analysis ago i think yeah the
analog here
is that as the virus becomes rare
then our data is increasingly polluted
by erroneous
reports in other words if the virus were
at zero then studying false reports of
it would give us a wrong sense of what
it was doing
and what kind of effects it was having
on the body so that's just something we
need to be cautious about
that's absolutely true and we actually
talked about um the sort of the early
side of that problem early on when rates
were going up
rates were still you know the number of
cases are still very low and we talked
about
why false positives are going to
make the rate seem like it's much higher
than it is when you have a very low
background rate in the population yeah
[Music]
exactly